hey I'm crushing harloff and I'm Tiffany
Smith and this is our special Halloween
episode so we've got food for this
episode we have the star of scouts guide
to the zombie apocalypse Sarah Dumas and
this is movie 3d
[Music]
thank you so much for joining us you
have your big movie coming up tomorrow
the scouts guide to the zombie
apocalypse you I wanted to leave you
feel at home because you've been around
Sammy's a lot and your movie set so well
I feel really I don't feel like I want
to touch you well I feel huh it was
really really good at all by herself I
thought it was a little finger lash but
well let's not even talk about that
Christian because I do believe you were
supposed to have something makeup too so
we just want to hear a little bit about
it from you without giving any spoilers
what was your favorite part of the
production my favorite part is was just
a stunts I like doing something I'm
total on wit hi I love doing stunts and
like watching [ __ ] blow up but then also
work in a comedy set and just constantly
pranking each other and goofing off not
at the time a little bit off like say
Zombieland yeah with that mix of the
horror we're coming is that why it's all
attracted you to the role was the comedy
as well and what attracted me to the
role with the nice way play is actually
very strong and independent and they're
sure of herself and whoops ass and saves
the boys instead of being that too girly
like for a movie like oh my god make
sure it's wet and then I died any more
questions can we do something about his
face she went all out I feel very
comfortable I mean zombie mood it's
Halloween and then here you are I mean
what is your costume a dork I feel like
you need just a little something Oh what
did you now what did you do remember
that when you lost last week remember we
had a really busy episode see we're a
team yes Harry Potter friends you know
can make me feel better in this scenario
let's talk about the weekly wager
I love the weekly wager you know why
because I usually win I'm actually aware
of the weekly wager last week and it was
about revenues of the last witch hunter
right yep you went for 13.5 million and
you went for a walk went by yes ends up
for the last 100
so a box-office revenue was ten point
eight million which means this week's
punishment comes from long column this
week spanish mint comes from one of our
YouTube viewers Johnny b-45 who says
loser should has to eat a bowl of fried
crickets Johnny B by the way second
punishment that you have submitted buddy
you submit some great punishments looks
so tasty
I feel like Bradley Cooper and burn this
is Bradley Cooper all goodness for me
wait more something to eat alright so
tasty Tiffany so lovely look at whole
bowl here we go alright are you ready my
love Thomas the Train - - it's not that
bad is it
it's like sunflower seeds okay
good half three no weekly wager for you
next week alright let's bet on Scouts
guy through the zombie apocalypse you
better bet hi [ __ ] I'm standing
right here okay I'm gonna say eight
point four for zombie apocalypse TIFF I
want to win what do you say $1 you gonna
still be nice to her no on YouTube on
Facebook on Twitter and make us both be
way wrong and go see this movie a [ __ ]
ton this weekend let's just get today's
topic okay Sarah no no today I was
trying to find out exactly how to
survive a zombie apocalypse our crew put
together a little survival pack behind
you there there's one yeah that one
right there wants to eat in that bag
it's a little heavy they were really
impressed with themselves first up a
plastic clarinet not a good start
give me your fiber one bars in case you
need to like load up and then [ __ ] your
pants because this is the only thing
that the [ __ ] the package bag is gonna
be doing
trying their best finding DVD this could
be very useful it's very heavy can of
you know piece art our crew pretty much
just watches zombie of Chile another
another ingredient I'm [ __ ] your
pants
nice this is never gonna happen for
anyone on this set all right you're
never gonna need these that is a wishful
thinking yeah but you know I like these
these are condoms a packet of condoms
simple office today all right this is by
far my favorite you get tied up in a
little like Costco warehouse we got
hours to kill Sara what would you rate
this one the time for diarrhea I know
our survival kit was pretty sucky but
something awesome that we did do is
we've got some real weapons in a new
segment that we like to call movies oh
[Applause]
I'll tell you that now we actually have
real weapons so for you because I feel
like you're the most defenseless I'm
gonna give you the most badass weapon
that we have here very army of Darkness
just like ash just keep it away from my
face our crew out there they have set up
pumpkins I'm gonna go rack them I'm not
gonna hit anything up and you guys
talking yet yeah yeah okay go do a set
facing away from our hate both of you
[Music]
[Music]
he really needs to work out I mean this
guy is clearly flabbergasted
you should see a doctor
what question might be all right tell
you what watching Star Wars is not a
good workout okay
they're about us ya think no that's how
you do it
no look at that
[Music]
alright alright she's already done you
seen 20 days later they took notes from
her that's how it's true I want to do
one more though you can do one little
but I'm gonna I'm gonna choose for you
this is a very special weapon my me mom
eat it
she's a very talented person so do you
like marshmallows and I roast by a fire
somewhere what is this sometimes it is
Omni apocalypse you don't always get
what you want right alright let's go you
can do it yeah he's not gonna do [ __ ]
with that is he he's having way too much
fun with the scarf and pumpkins I don't
I just why don't we just wrap up the
show I think that's a good call ok I'm
all for joining us and make sure you
guys check out her movie in theaters
tomorrow scouts guide to the zombie
apocalypse and follow her on social
media Dumont Sarah and while you're here
make sure you check out more videos
right over there and subscribe and don't
forget you guys download the Fandango
movie clips app on your smartphone so
you guys can see us next week on movie
[Applause]
what I mean I gotta get me some points I
really didn't think you had a